frankly American forms of dissent and
free speech and I support both of my
support that's just it
so you think there's a difference yes
between the black students at Yale
protesting whatever I forget what you
know questionable thing that professor
said and the conservative students in
this case protesting go ahead now and
now I'll stay for this looks here sunny
it just got sunny here after being snowy
and cold all day alright I got I got a
go away I know we'll keep it sure we'll
keep it short I do people I have to tell
you can I just say that your people are
very nice well thank you you're being a
core right now I know I'm just saying hi
I what do you have a name for them are
they the just some of them are crowd or
heads
well I listen I don't try and I just
agree with you that's humanly on some of
these things but I do try and I do take
some pride in effect I think our
audiences is they're pretty decent
people and he always gets some people
not overwhelmingly I was very very
impressed Bob let me also just say I
think we should do the next time we do
this we should do it where we try to
find I don't know how many we can do
five 10 things we agree on okay don't
just mean like movies I mean politically
cuz I actually suspect there there's
more than you think well I think we do I
mean I think we all agree on no I think
we I think most people can agree on 90%
of issues the problem is is that
politically and media-wise and whatever
an Internet wise we fight on that 5 or
10 percent well here's one thing that we
run into we're not nearly as if you
actually if people who actually watch
the program we're not nearly as divided
across political lines however I am far
more straightforward and having you on
where I'll say no I disagree with that
and we're just not going to find common
ground there where's a lot of people who
say oh yeah and they shrink when they
get on the cable network and they go
back to the radio show and [ __ ] like
they're a tough guy I try and keep it
the same across the board so we keep it
100 all the time I keep it real all the
time bro I keep you so real you don't
even know bro
I keep it real like a Christmas tree I
don't know evergreen fakes they get from
flower land I bought my tree from flower
and that's me really yeah victory yeah I
choose a real tree I just want you to
know that I know
Jewish tree is a real trial done but
by the Jews my partner's Christian so I
mean it's it's like it's it's it's a
what I was about to say bipartisan
chamber house with your business put
multi it's a great going back to the
free speech issue oh yeah that professor
given a vote completely false and
slanderous attacks on Donald Trump but
he's a racist he's a xenophobe if she
said listen Donald Trump is hypocritical
because of A or B policies fine that's
not what this professor said student
recorded any student recorded it
released it then threatened by the
professor's Union to expel him now some
individuals after that sent death
threats to this teacher we've dealt with
actual death threats we've actually done
with FBI's counterterrorism unit so we
don't talk about a lot as have I but
yeah I definitely think that the
censorship of free speech in that
situation would be exclusively on the
shoulders of the left I think that's
fascinating considering it was the right
that sent the death threats and forced
the teacher into hiding but why do we
have to pick signs on this in other
words why can't why can't we say why do
you thority right claiming they're
trying to systematically silence and
intimidate voices I'm not talking about
Twitter using but to be clear every
other conversation I've had on about
political correctness and free speech
under attack from supposedly under
attack from the left accusations that
you and your fellow conservatives have
made are about students and non
institutional actors from the left and
they represent the level I need to clamp
down on free speech that well I'm that's
just true the three or four college
discussions I've had have on this topic
have all been focused on that angle so
it's not though it's not doing so that's
not true because our issue is with
professors unions our issue is with the
Dean of Admissions our organization's
banning other speech not sending
individual abreast it's it's also about
the student groups or the students
individual students organizing protests
and shouting down speakers and all of
that so I'm just saying the critiques
haven't just been institutional but
Steven the larger point is the larger
point
they're not just saying we don't like
you they're going to get people banned
whether it's Ben Shapiro or myself or
Miley innopolis they're not just saying
we don't like you that's what
conservatives do with the lactase we get
the professor's unions and the Dean and
the student unions and try and get words
banned that is the big point Sally I I
and I'm against it so that's my point
here is I'm saying but why do you want
to make this a partisan issue when I
would think this would be something we
could unite around I believe in free
speech we should support free speech by
the way disconcerting is also
president-elect Trump saying he's gonna
change libel law to crackdown on
journalists who say things he doesn't
like we should be against all of this I
took me against I can be against the the
professors and student groups attacking
free speech I can be against hate
mongers and conservative student groups
you know trying to clamp down speech - I
also want to be clear I support but I
but I do I do
they never do I'm saying conservatives
don't try and shut down free speech on
campus it is a word is it an issue if
it's only one side doing it so I bet I
agree with you would you let me just be
the SI would you agree the professor's
Union was wrong and threatening just
threatening the student for releasing
this tape of the teacher which I
probably would yes I think yeah so again
I haven't looked at the details of like
why and what they were claiming whatever
but but instinctively I think that's
wrong I remember when Yale students were
protesting against I don't remember what
the Dean of one of the colleges had said
something it was like six months ago and
the Yale students were protesting and
calling on that professor to be fired
and I recall being on conservative radio
shows where they were attacking the
students for doing that that the
students are clamping down on free
speech that they're trying to police
speech on the campus yes it seems to me
that if you're gonna make that
accusation you're gonna have to make the
same accusation about the conservative
political group and the Young
Republicans at this campus going after
this professor now I happen to think
folks are legitimate and and and and
frankly American forms of dissent and
free speech and I support both of my
support that's just stupid
so you think there's a difference yes
between the black students at Yale
protesting whatever I forget what you
know questionable thing that professor
said
the conservative students in this case
protesting go ahead now and now I'll
stay for this let's hear it okay you
will hear for this okay one is people
trying to get a professor for saying
something to get a professor fired for
saying something that they found
offensive another is students this
should be actually something you would
agree with when we talk about sort of
hierarchy of oppression or Authority
students who don't have the authority
who don't run the system protesting a
corrupt professors Union trying to boot
a kid for doing the right thing so one
is try and against the system they're
trying to get the teacher fire that's
what they're trying to do so it's the
same thing it's a student's organizing
their future self Steven man I'm sorry
but you're on the wrong side on this
here's the thing there's sauce the tape
they talked about this gave the
professor the airtime that she's so
willingly used when she thought cameras
weren't recording and now they're upset
and professors you know I just got to be
in for doing that big trouble
cuz I'm gonna be late and I do adore you
except you're on the wrong side on this
one but let's go I'm it is fun
incorrect Sally we'll have you back and
you can have that list of five things we
agree upon what you don't they will put
end card here just tell people to
subscriber lists from the full shell
well this is end card is going up
whether you like it or not boxes just
well now we've already done it people
are gonna subscribe because you told
them not to reverse psychology
now you just did it unknowingly I get a
mugger yes